we're in problem 13
problem 13 and they say
if
4x
is equal to 6u which is equal to 5v
which is equal to 7w
all of which is greater than zero
which of the following is true
so they're essentially wanting you to
order
w to
they want you to order these terms from
in order from least to greatest so one
thing i'm going to do is let me order
these terms from the coefficients from
least to greater so that's the same
thing as 4x is equal to 5
v which is equal to 6u which is equal to
7w right and they're all greater than 0.
so let me so what's going to be the
great greater x or w
so if i have 4 of something and that
equals 7 of this thing this is going to
be the smallest right
think of it this way
if
x could be
if x was
if x was 7
then w would be 4. try that out if x was
7 then this term would be 28 then w
would be 4. so w is the smallest and by
that same principle
u is going to be next so w is less than
u which is less than v
which is less than x and it's just on
the principle you know if if it takes me
seven
of something to make up the four of
something else this thing has to be
bigger because i need fewer of it to
make seven of this thing and by the same
logic
u is less than v right because you need
six of that thing to make one of v i
mean if you really wanted to
if you if you wanted to kind of try it
out you could divide all of these by
four and you'd get
x is equal to five fourths v which is
equal to six fourth u is equal to seven
fourths w
all of these terms are greater than one
so x is more than
more than all of these and you could do
it for all of these and you would see
that same order that whichever one has
the highest coefficient is going to be
the smallest number and then the next
smallest is going to be u then v then x
so let's see what choice that is w is
less than u which is less than v which
is less than x and that's choice d
problem 14.
let the function h be defined by
h of t
is equal to
2 times t square t cubed sorry t cubed
minus three
when h of t
is equal to minus sixty so h of t
is equal to minus sixty
what is 2
minus 3t
what is 2 minus 3t so let's see what we
can
what we can what we can do here 2 minus
3t
so h of t is equal to minus 60. so minus
60 is equal to 2
times
t cubed minus 3
fair enough
and then divide both sides by 2. i'm
just trying to see where i can go with
this divide both sides by 2
so you get
minus 30
is equal to t cubed minus 3.
add 3 to both sides you get minus 27
is equal to t cubed
oh and this is pretty straightforward
something to the third power is equal to
minus 27 well what's the cube root of 27
it's 3 so the cube root of minus 27 is
minus 3.
so t is equal to minus 3. and you could
try that out what's minus 3 to the third
power minus 3 times minus 3 is 9 times
-3 is minus 27.
so when h of t is minus 60
t is equal to -3 and so what is 2 minus
3t which is what they asked us
originally it's going to be 2 minus 3
times minus 3
so it's 2
minus minus 9
or 2 plus 9 which is equal to 11.
and that is choice b
next problem
i will switch colors where was i
my brain is fried from doing all of
these sat problems but i figured i'd do
it once and it will be there forever for
students for the rest of eternity to
learn sat problems and compete with my
future children and they'll be angry way
problem 15
if x is divisible by 3
and y is divisible by 5 which of the
following must be divisible by 15.
so x
divisible
by 3 so x is a multiple of 3. you can
kind of view it that way
y is divisible
by 5. which of the following must also
be divisible
by 15. do you know how i'm going to do
it i'm going to say look you could say
write this you just write x is equal to
3k where k is some integer right we
don't know what multiple x is of 3 but
we know
3 times some integer k is equal to x and
somewhere you could say y is equal to 5
i don't know 5m where you could say some
integer m
times 5 is equal to y right because we
know that 5 times something is equal to
y that's what divisible means
so let's look at the choices
1.
they want to know which of the ones are
divisible by 15. so choice 1 is x times
y right well x times y is the same thing
as let's multiply as 3k
times 5m
and that's the same thing as 15
km
so that's xy is the same thing as 15
times the product of two integers and
the product of two integers is going to
be an integer right
so this is definitely divisible by 15.
so choice one is divisible by 15.
problem two
problem two
three x
plus
3x plus 5y so we can do the same thing
x is 3k so that's 3 times 3k
plus 5y plus 5
times
5m plus 5 times 5m that equals 9k
plus 25m
this isn't necessarily divisible by 15.
i mean what if k and m are both 1 right
then you get 34 and this is not
divisible by 15. all right choice 3
choice 3
5x
plus 3y
doing the same thing that equals 5 times
3k right this is x
5 times 3 k plus 3
times 5 m
and this equals 15
k
plus 15 m
and you can factor out the 15 right
that's 15 times k plus m
and once again so this thing is equal to
15 times k plus m k plus m is going to
be some integer right we said k and m
are both integers so this term right
here is definitely divisible by 15. so 1
and 3 are our answer
and that is choice d
and you know if you didn't want to do
this fancy stuff where you say it's
multiplying by some integer etcetera
etcetera
just you know x is divisible by 3 y is
equal by 5. well let's just say x is
equal to 3
and y is equal to 5 and then try them
out then
xy is going to be 15 which is of course
divisible by 15.
this would be let's see 3 times 3 plus 5
times 5 this would be 34 not divisible
by 15.
and then the final one 3 times 5 is 15
plus 3 times 5 is 15. this would be 30
which is divisible by 15. so that would
have been kind of the quick and dirty
not necessarily the most mathematically
rigorous way of doing it but it would
have gotten you the right answer and
that really is what matters i guess on
the sct
that would have been the quick and dirty
solution let me see if i can draw this
thing
okay
and then one line like that one line
like that
one line
something like that
and what do they tell us about this
is yellow
they tell us that this angle right here
is 115 degrees
this is line l
this is z degrees
line m
line n and this is y degrees looks like
we're going to play the angle game here
this is y degrees in the figure above
what is y plus z
y plus z
so when i play the angle game i just try
to figure out as many sides as i can so
if this is 115 what is this going to be
well 115 plus this is supplementary
right
so these are going to add up to be 180.
so this is going to be 180 minus 115.
what's 80 minus 15 it's 65 right because
80 minus 10 is
70. so this is 65 degrees and i just
said that because this angle plus this
has to be 180 right
now what is this angle right here
this angle right here is going to be 180
minus y for the same reason because it's
supplementary to y
this angle here same reason is going to
be 180 minus z
180 minus z
and we know this angle plus this angle
plus this angle has to add up to 180. so
65 plus 180 minus y
plus
180 minus z is equal to 180.
let's see you can
so that's what's let's see
you could subtract
180 from both sides you get a 0 here
what's 65 plus 180 65 plus 180 is
245
minus y minus z is equal to zero
add y and z to both sides you get 245
is equal to y
plus z and that is choice e
see in the next video